my friends my friends you already know
that genius brain listeners have to be
listening to this podcast with raycon
what is raycon my friends raycon is
premium audio at the perfect price point
so you can listen to what you want when
you want without breaking the bank my
friends and I'll tell you this right now
I love my raycon earbuds because guess
what I'm an audio newbie and even though
I'm an audio newbie I want good sound
quality without breaking the bank and
that's where raycon comes in I'll tell
you this right now their custom gel tips
are perfect they're super comfortable
Crystal Clear call Quality Water and
sweat resistant and eight hours of play
time and a whole bunch more functions
for the right price go to buy raycon.com
today to get 15 off your raycon order
that's by raycon.com to score 50 off by
raycon.com brain so Michael Jackson was
it a limo
Oprah then the girl came up with the
titties yes he goes God damn look at
them things
I'm like this motherfucker's weird he's
weird so that's what I saw that he
didn't did all those kids okay yeah no
way a kid did five four three two one
hello everybody this is uh number one
North Korean podcast
I do this in the basement if I get found
eighth generation of according people
die
and today we have a number one Chinese
companion Nick the ear
he uh woke up one day in a garbage can
somebody pound them and they're like hey
maybe I keep him around and then there
you go he's over here
he's the guy right here so Russian
colored t-shirt looks like he's a made
out of potato sack
next we have this guy he's like a white
guy but he's not he's a brown person
never makes sense at all
always only speak Spanish even though
he's a white boy
oh God
what's your intro [__] my name
is David saw it's a number one on the
ground in North Korea never lose I hate
the Japanese people all the time
if you're like a sushi you're gay
[Laughter]
I wish I could just talk like that all
the time I think people would never take
me seriously at all though it's really
good you could say racist things you can
say [__] sexist things and nobody
would take you seriously and it's kind
of sweet the way you say it
women don't like to stay in a kitchen
and barefoot
I don't understand how come they never
give you sex when you ask
why do I need to ask a permission you
are made of poor me
wow I have to ask yeah that's the
question yeah wow that's a crazy I never
asked it's a pig
yeah by the way guys this is a character
I'm kidding this is a this is a North
Korean if you guys don't know I used to
do YouTube a lot there was a character
named Kim jong-ila I used to do he was a
North Korean character I legit used to
do this guy and he was the number one he
was so arrogant he was number one at
everything but he was just a North
Korean dictator and everybody would lie
so number one basketball player number
one husband number one everything and
that's why he's an [__] I don't want
to get canceled that's why you can't
cancel me I'm uncancelable I think
you're fine dude Kim jong-ila Great Name
by the way well yes it started off as
the number one rapper and then he went
to number one husband number one
basketball player you telling me Kim
jong-ila got bars he has a bars watch
today give me okay yeah hey my name is a
Kim jong-ira he's a number one rapper in
all about North Korea give me one topic
I must be the hot fire
tell me right now give me give me your
number one topic I spit a hot pirate go
ahead I never lose sandwiches sandwiches
okay Hey listen I understand with Chi it
has a lot of meat too
this is my penis you bet I beat her all
day this guy Pat has a big did I don't
care he's a white boy he has a hair
yeah
hey I'd never lose
every day number one basketball player
LeBron James
he's our number one steroid abuser
nobody say I never use a steroid
foreign
[Music]
it was super [__] fun well I feel
like you know no one you could probably
so you could say you're North Korean
anything and everyone is like wrong they
would trip if you did that character
enough you know what I don't like I
think people just don't care about like
thought out content they just want 60
second content ever since like the onset
of um like Vine was really one that
started it off like one of the content
that I hate the most is people when they
set up a [__] camera and it's a
couple doing couples arguing [__] and
it's the worst actors ever and they just
sit in the corner hey babe so uh I'm
gonna go out with Peter what do you
think oh you're gonna go up here uh when
you come back oh you know just you know
we're just gonna come back whenever you
know and then there's the robotic voice
in the band my boyfriend is the Chalice
type
so I guess I'm gonna come with you no no
no is this it's just me and Peter we're
gonna have dinner okay
oh my god dude [__] go die by the way
if you're an Asian person you do that
you're an idiot and I do not claim you
at all I hate you you're an Asian very
specific okay Asian couples do that [__]
online well it's just so lame that [__]
is cringy as [__] it's just it's so
cringy you want another subsect of like
a couple stuff that I see I don't know
why I see it but it's like girls who are
dating guys who are way older than them
and their whole page is like based on
that and it's like why like a sugar
daddy maybe your sugar daddy maybe
they're just like insecure about like
their situation being a sugar daddy
situation so they have to claim that
like oh I like them because like he's
old like he's older so like there's
parts of the relationship and they have
all these [__] Lane posts and they
use the robot voice and then yeah
I hate it dude I'm 22. he's 45 and they
do like stupid [__] answers and I'm
like dude who cares nobody cares dude
yeah I don't care into retirement and
why is this on my feet
one of the things I wish too is like
those people like I wish somebody would
just delete their account and hack them
because I want to see their reaction
because their whole life is based on
people validating their relationship
like Oh I wanna oh my God couples goals
really I bet he beats you no I'm kidding
I'm kidding but that's wild though right
to live like that like just like having
everyone else's validation about your
[__] I literally talked to my mom
about this today in the car and then she
was just talking about how long I've
been on the space and I said mom like
the reason why I've been able to survive
on the space because I actually have
friends you know like some of these
other kids and like it's like every time
I talk they always say the same [__] I
don't have any friends in the city it's
because you're a loser
did you ever realize that yeah did you
ever wake up in the morning in the
camera and tell them right there hey you
don't have friends because you're a
[__] loser dude that's true that's
something you could change yeah you
could change that instantly yeah stop
look your fans are not your friends
there's people who appreciate your
content they're not your [__] friends
they don't know you right and you know
maybe like look I've had a fan too that
he actually became a friend his name is
um Donovan
rude Koji he's a videographer he's a
dancer and I connected with him just
because I liked his content and it turns
out he's a nerd like me and then we
really [__] connected and we became
friends but that didn't happen overnight
like we became friends over time and so
it was weird when I see these kids they
go I can't make any friends it's because
your perception of friendship is what
you see online you want to do the whole
oh let's do a reel together let's do all
this other [__] I've had [__] like
kids who are really popular who got
popular on like um Tick-Tock and [__]
that were fans of mine and immediately
they go hey can we do a video again no I
don't know you like Villa so they'll
they'll try to do that of like the first
interaction with you yeah it's just
really odd but I think the the mistake
that I'm making is that I think that's
their generation they don't care hey
dude you want to collab with me you want
to make a tick tock with me I don't yeah
and they think that when you saw me for
forever dude I still don't want to do it
yeah there you go
this is the weirdest thing ever and so
when I say no they take it offensively
and they go oh it's oh because you think
you're better than me it's like no I
just don't want how come I just don't I
can't do it because I don't want to do
it yes right now right right how come I
can't say no it's because it's in their
world yeah hey this is the numeral oh
they're North Korean oh yeah I forget
the North Korean I said no they're like
I'm not asking poor consent this is a
demand yeah yeah I like how he just says
like a demon demon yeah
the gym couple videos first of all gym
videos people that record themselves
like like ads I gotta Speak Easy
[__] are like baby oiled up
I've seen like camera crews around dudes
cringy as [__] but I've also seen the
couple videos like like a guy helping
this girl Squat and then or the caption
was like he has my back when the weight
is too bad
dude it's so cringy and it's like in
slow motion he's like yeah gorgeous babe
she's like it like Zooms in and she like
ah and then she like goes back like she
couldn't the first time and then he like
helps her and then she does it the
second time or the ones where like
couples are like doing like the guys
doing the push-up and the girl's like on
his back or something like yeah like the
[__] hacky [__] dude I love it it's
like what what are you you're like what
are you are you what person is this yeah
this is and who is this for like who's
watching this [__] like oh dude this is
me like I get that I like Vibe with it I
saw a gym video this dude was running on
a treadmill
I think I sent it to you he's got a
weighted vest and he's running on those
treadmills that's kind of a curve where
you can really Sprint on and it's in
slow motion and he has the 300 Spartans
like what is your profession
you know that part of them he's running
a slow motion sprinting it's like dude
like you're not going to war you're
jogging you're running you're jogging in
an air-conditioned room
you idiot
what the [__] are you doing dude yeah I
love that comparison to like dude this
is war dude what is your profession this
is on a treadmill like
what the [__] is this but the thing is
like it gets millions of views yeah and
like I I maybe it's listen I like social
media I think it's dope the problem is
is like the youth their whole life is
just now they don't have any like
outside experience right and like I I
think like the level of sensitivity that
I've seen from younger people it kind of
is astounding it's not all young people
by the way right they're still like
young people who think that this is dumb
and you know that's probably like the
fan base that I have but when I see
people who were just constantly offended
by everything it's like how do you live
like this there are people I know that
are like peers of mine that they cannot
read negative comments because it blows
their mind that somebody dislikes the
things that they do blows their [__]
mind they cry over it they literally cry
over it like okay well if I put up this
post okay if I say this it might be
people might consider this offensive
you're not that important nobody [__]
cares about you like that like the the
level of how narcissistic are you that
you think that people actually give that
many [__] about you right like legit
okay let's say you have a million
followers right you have 500 000 400 000
followers guess what if you die tomorrow
they're moving on like that you'll get
one post though you get at least a post
there you go dude check this out so so
do you know this guy named jackfruit
so Jackfruit is like an Asian news media
Source right on Instagram they post a
lot of like Asian hate stuff and also a
lot of like other funny comedians that
are Asian American or whatever right and
it was this guy named David so it turned
out yesterday that he committed suicide
and he put up this post that was you
know that sign that somebody's gonna off
himself a little bit and I know it was
the song he posted something before yeah
you can see it on here I'll I'll find it
right now but uh he's been on the space
for a while he's reposted a lot of my
[__]
um really nice dude oh here's so
Jackfruit f-r-o-t so 241 000 followers
right and he had a post oh they took it
down took it down they took down the
post where he wrote this is almost like
his final goodbye I wish it was there
but now it's just like all his in loving
memory stuff but he basically wrote kind
of like an alarming thing where it made
it seem like he was going to kill
himself right
and everybody's gonna check on your
people everything else like that here
here's my take on that and people may
agree or disagree like what the [__] did
you think was going to happen for a guy
where his whole existence now is him
finding Asian people getting beat up
burned all this negative [__] yeah like
when you live on your if you're already
mentally unstable and your whole life is
based on comments and likes that is your
identity yeah mentally it's going to
[__] you up so he runs the whole page I
thought it was like a couple of dudes
maybe I think he ran the page mainly I
could be wrong and the only reason I'm
saying by the way this isn't critique or
anything I'm just saying like I feel for
him yeah because because you you have
friends and like we all have friends
this is my space yeah so I do this [__]
and then they read comments and like
that really does [__] with their mental
it [__] with them and also too like the
stuff that he's posting a lot of it is
funny stuff and it's um you know cool
content but the other 60 70 is this
person getting burned alive this racist
[__] this all this other stuff it's
really easy to see the like the worst in
people and this is the stuff he has to
hunt for every yeah because that's what
gets gets clicks that's what people want
to see they want to see [__] their [__]
in their feed to start off their day
dude yeah sometimes like you don't think
that's gonna [__] them up like sure it's
gonna [__] him up yeah and so when
people are like I'm surprised this
happened how are you surprised when
you're when your job is to look for [__]
all the time and then that's what you
live in every [__] day yeah right
that's what social media is right like
you you just find something that's
popular so you can get validated 24
[__] seven that's why I just want to
see what happens to people if somebody
just magically went like this yeah I
delete Instagram Twitter and your
[__] Tick Tock dude there was girls
oh there's a girl who [__] cried
because her Tick Tock got deleted and
she said my life is [__] over like I
have nothing to live for she's bawling
because she goes my life is over I'm
like your life is over she goes this was
my career it was your career yeah right
look it like at the end of the day too
it's like so this whole time you didn't
develop this into anything else besides
you dressing up in clothes and doing
dances with your titties out and you
expected this to be to last forever
right
hey let me tell you something I jacked
off to her
dog the weirdest thing I ever see people
who set up a camera and cry oh bro that
is banana have you seen the ones with
the nurses no no oh dude the nurses are
[__] crazy so it's like they'll set
up a camera
and then they'll walk out in front of
the camera obviously and then she'll be
like I see this I've seen a couple of
these videos she'll start crying and
then the caption be like I lost another
patient today
and then it'll like it'll go dot dot dot
just a couple more hours get through the
day blah blah blah blah right so like
she's
a nurse yes he's on the job and she's
like I feel so sad about my patient
dying
instead of this tripod real quick oh
Jesus Christ in the meantime someone
else is dying because they need oxygen
and you're over here
yeah you're ruining my Tick Tock and
then she sits off to the side and she's
like
yeah I feel like nurses are crazy bro
some nurses are like kind of a crazy
demographic of people huh this is my
favorite
I look I actually like this shot because
it's really great for like on a film
perspective but it's when you when you
take yourself out of it and you realize
what this person did it's pretty [__]
hilarious it's like get ready with me
and then oh yeah and the shot is them
waking up
I'm like somebody set up that camera and
turn it on so that means you uh woke up
set it up yeah crawled right back and
then you went
[Laughter]
we watch these travel YouTubers and
they're great they're called like Cara
Nate or whatever and they always every
[__] no they'll do like really
luxurious stuff and they'll do like
Vlogs that awaken they're sleeping in
the middle of a beach with like little
sand crabs everywhere biting the [__]
out of them but they always do that shot
in the morning
oh and they get up and Tiff always goes
like do they set that camera up every
single time a hundred percent they have
to they have to that's it first of all
nobody wakes up like a [__] Disney
cartoon yeah you're right you know how I
wake up I go oh come on my dick is hard
should I jack off
yeah
and I get up my face is all below to
this [__] my eyes are swollen [__] ID
don't recognize you exactly like who is
this [__] ogre it's my phone will
wake up I get my eye drops
and I wake up I see my [__] wife
snoring her ass off I'm like hey shut up
shut up still doesn't wake up doesn't
wake up still that's a normal morning
dude yeah whenever I see that [__] I'm
like that's hilarious like sit from a
cinematic point of view it looks great
but just me thinking it from the outside
cracks me what I had to do to get that
shot hop out of bed or some [__] I love
it but I don't mind when the girls half
naked have you ever woken up like this
ever dude never wrist like this yeah
could you imagine them doing that [__]
and then the the framing is off they
gotta do it again yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah or they trip on the way over so
your wrist should never be like this I
don't think everything ever ever in any
situation ever your wrist should never
be like this ever yeah unacceptable
unacceptable behavior for a man I don't
want a kiss in the face yeah instantly
100 if you're a guy you wake up like
that
like like actually you should be punched
in the face yeah on Sunday yeah they
should neuter you
know North Korea now should not be able
to write you're doing North Korean
accent and say that [__] [__]
salacious [__] again you know I don't
really have a good North Korea can you
coach me through like a good Korean
accent okay so I always go that's
actually pretty good though that's
that's what I like if you ever want to
imitate a crimper that's actually what
cream sounds like I'm not even kidding
that's that's because I love especially
after watching yeah
I love the way Korean people speak it's
just so like expressive it kind of wants
me like Cantonese it's very expressive
yeah yeah I love it dude those people
that show made me feel like a piece of
[__] yeah dude
did you watch it with the dub though no
absolutely not dude how would you do
that because it's the dub is so bad why
do they have the worst hilarities it's
actually really funny I really want to
see you grab that rock he's so strong
awesome try again
what the [__] bro and they dumped the
size even like even like the if the guy
goes early guys they gotta go oh like
they even saw like their little like
their little things they didn't have to
dude wow so explosive arms powerful yeah
it's been like like people talk like
that yeah yeah exactly which is so
[__] hilarious but that physical 100
show was so interesting because I just
didn't know Korean people could get
buffed like dude they're all rich you
see the guy looks like sexy yeah
dude who did it is it over did somebody
wins over yeah who won it
um I didn't see the last episode but the
ice climber guy or something ice climb
that's wrong it was a cross figure I uh
you know what I actually cried on one of
the episodes it was the one hey don't
look at me like I'm gay
it was the one it was the one with uh
sexy Yama and he was uh doing a little
MMA match with the guy oh yeah yeah
she made me tear up why you know what it
was man hey make fun of this dude right
all right you know what it was because
it was nice to see somebody get to do
something with his hero uh because he
really really looked up to him and he
got to do this man-to-man type of moment
with the guy that he idolizes yeah and
he got to do it in the way that he
wanted to do it they kind of just slap
boxed a little bit yeah and you know
what made me cry because I felt the same
way about how you felt like watching
that but it was with the bodybuilder the
female bodybuilder going against the MMA
guy oh that guy beat the [__] out of
here the MMA guy beating her up I was
like yeah dude
I'd love to see him
was a [__] creep dude yeah everybody
was like oh I don't like this people are
like try and get it there was an MMA
yeah like he just kept doing this he
thought he was [__] he thought he was
Jon Jones yes he was like the he was
like this like skinny little scrawny MMA
dude and he was like I guess the female
bodybuilder picked him and it was the
one where they had to fight for the
medicine ball yeah and he just was like
[__] her ass up and then he was like
kind of being smug about it which is
like so not cool like he was trying to
look cool beating her ass like Judo is
his thing oh okay so it's just like hip
tops just flipping the [__] out of her
dude he had his knee into her [__]
stomach she couldn't do [__] yeah wow
and it was all technique versus strength
and so this guy was tossing her ass
around dude and he's like just walking
like a cool guy to the medicine ball
like yeah literally the gate opened and
his hands were in his pocket yeah cool
guy and then uh they were screaming and
one of the people were like you have to
try harder and he looks at the girl he
goes
to be quiet and then they were the girl
was like [__] like oh this guy's creepy
he scares me he's like a murderer he was
just creepy yeah did he make it far on
the show he made it pretty far but then
he lost because his team lost so that
whole team got eliminated oh it turned
into teams yeah
yeah that makes me want to be fit yeah
those [__] are yoked yeah and
then they would out of nowhere have like
a crossing guard or something for us
they had like the dopest specimens like
Navy SEAL special like Olympic [__]
world lip and then like hey a [__]
substitute teacher
there's an old lady that walks on my
street I tell her you better hurry it up
I said my specialty why the [__] is the
substitute teacher here with these guys
the worst episode the most mismatch was
that buff
um prison guard versus the [__]
Olympian wrestler oh yeah and he double
legged the [__] out of it he was tossing
around was it the same contest the
medicine ball or was the medicine ball
that one was so unfair because he he
suplexed him yeah suplexed a guy that
was like 260 pounds wow over and over
over and over he took his back and he
full on suplexed him dude wow and he
afterwards too you know usually people
like Dap You Up or something no dabs he
just told me get the [__] out of there
wow he was so [__] into it
damn like creepy people have a chip on
their shoulder dude like when I saw him
I'm like that's the most Korean thing he
could have done really I get the [__]
out of here like you're you're like my
little brother like you're not on my
level I feel like there's opposite sides
of the spectrum though yeah they're
really polite of their [__] yeah
like I feel like all the Korean people
are that I meet are very extremely nice
and then the other is like thank you
David so but you're not you're you're
you're you you're a sweetheart deep down
dude no I'm a sweetheart all around shut
the [__] up what are you talking about
I'm hella nice
she always berates us yeah yeah yeah I'm
the nicest [__] ever dude hey
dude we're United We're not gonna take
it anymore yeah okay yeah really excuse
me
last time
okay terrible but he's a father okay we
have no time we have no time you know
what's really sad about that you were
holding his hand but he wasn't holding
her back that's why I was telling him to
[__] squeeze
you know what someone uh when they first
saw I I forgot it was this lady I was
talking to when squid Games first came
out she was like the acting is just so
bad like this is bad acting and then I
was like what a [__] she was like
they're just so like expressive and like
to and I was like I think they're just
being Korean like
I don't think like they're great actors
actually dude I talked to this guy I was
like hey man have you seen parasite he
goes yeah man parasite's a [__] up
movie he's like what's up with Korean
people man are they doing okay we're
saying that yeah yeah he was like he's
like he's like why is it so dark like
what's going on it's a great movie it's
a great movie yeah Korean [__] it's
always [__] up Korean people are
really good at right the Koreans are
killing it Korean people are really hot
because if you notice even in parasite
right they're number one ranked they're
the hottestation dude seriously I agree
hey this is the Japanese all right but
now Japanese had their time in the sun I
think it's Korean time now that's right
they have anime we have hot [__] hot
[__] the movies the [__] that's
coming out the movies the [__]
physical 100 everyone can't stop talking
about that dude that's a squid game
bring people on really good in film
because like we have a very weird and
odd sadistic sense of humor because even
in parasite how many parties were there
yeah it was funny yeah
all Korean like you'll never see a
Korean movie that's a horror film that
doesn't have a joke in it yeah it's
always like that they have to break up
the minority but that's that's the
secret to a good horror movie you need
to have some humor so sprinkled later
tonight go watch a movie called old boy
and then you will see that is one of the
most sick [__] movies you'll ever see
really that and I saw the devil also a
very sick movie I saw the devil I saw
the devil is one of my favorite movies
probably there's two movies that are my
favorite that's in like top three I saw
the devil I saw the devil as a as a
psycho thriller about a a cop who gets
his wife is murdered by a serial killer
and then the cop becomes basically he
hunts down the serial killer and
tortures him like Catch and Release dude
he'll capture him and then he'll knock
his ass out [__] him up like tear his
[__] up and then release him again so he
can catch him again that's so tight
Korean people love Revenge dude they do
it the best I love a good revenge and
that's wild yeah it's so old boy is so
good for that reason like it's Revenge
this is all Revenge so you if you love
Revenge watch old boy or watch I saw the
devil I'll try yeah I've heard of old
I've heard a lot of people recommend old
boy to me you're gonna watch some stuff
and like I saw the devil where you'd be
like oh my God I can't believe this is
happening like what's one of them give
me give me a little sneeze he finds a
pedophile he takes a steel pipe and
starts smashing his dick in oh and then
you see him hit his dick and his dick
breaks and it just curves like this oh
they show this I screamed all right
holy [__] bro that [__] shook him
so loud
I can't really show hard dick and smash
you see it through his tidy whities but
then you see him hit the dick and he
goes
oh my God bro dude honestly the cinema
like like I said parasite was [__]
fantastic squid games the [__] like
they're just [__] killing it yeah man
there's there's a role there's another
film called The Wailing that I really
liked it's a horror film uh I don't like
horror films but the Wailing is about
like Shamanism and like like demon [__]
but it's like a like a thriller horror
film and it's on Amazon I bought it for
like three bucks it's one of my favorite
films of all like Korean films are the
[__] man it's the only reason why I like
acting because we're making some
comedies bro you got some good Korean
comedies like I don't really like a
horror movies yes there's the my only
rom-com I ever liked is uh uh my sassy
girl they didn't like the name already
they did a version of that in in the
states and it bombed really yeah I was
in it
um there's two really famous actors
she's not so popular anymore because she
got a little older you're creating
people throwing old people like nothing
yes she's like 20s yeah
if you guys watch my sassy girl you'll
understand my humor got it so go watch
my sister girl it's it's literally about
a psychotic like girl like she's [__]
nuts but um this guy is such a [__]
goofball when I watch if you watch my
stats ago you look at the guy you'll be
like is this guy playing David yeah well
my mom watched that movie she goes oh
this guy reminds me of you and when I
watched it I'm like this is terrible
because he's a loser but it's one of my
favorite rom-coms of all time and I hate
rom-coms so my sassy girls up up there
that's really really funny I almost
forget that name my assassin girl I'm
gonna put Pat in my phone as my assassin
you'll love it dude your top G still on
my phone
if you guys don't know we did a podcast
about Andrew Tate and I got all the
information wrong and so it was like 30
minutes of me just just all the wrong
information so I decided not to put it
up
say I said he was innocent
I said all those other selection [__]
yeah I should have probably read a few
things
uh yeah because he was saying stuff like
um
he wasn't in jail I just got everything
wrong but I was only reading history is
there like not any information out
anyway what's going on what is actually
well he's in jail for human trafficking
and there's a lot of evidence against
him he probably was doing that [__] no
yeah and so I I don't people don't know
what's happening but this is the
interesting about the internet he was
the hottest thing on the internet right
those videos are so good his engagement
was through the roof I was commenting on
him tell him yeah you tell these women
tell these [__] two coffees I
said yeah that's Nick Dunn right there I
love two coffees that's my favorite bit
one two one just sits I drink one the
other one sits yeah just case I want it
just he would say stuff I think he was
very tactical about the things that he
would say right it was just so he was
playing a character I think he really
played up a character really well yeah
and the internet's professional fast one
month you don't see any of his stuff
anymore
even even if let's say he's in jail he
can't create he wasn't creating his
content but that's how much people don't
care about anything in this world
anymore yeah they only care about it if
it's the Hot Topic but once it moves on
they don't care like even somebody like
Logan Paul so transactional right I'm
not even talking about Logan Paul in
this than the suicide forest thing right
Logan Paul had his crypto Zoo scam he
stole Millions from people and he still
has a career how
people said he was gonna give it back he
hasn't though that's what he said that's
what he said dude let's check it out
always delivers he said he was going to
give back about like a mill something
right right and that was only for people
who bought the nft but what about The
Tokens The Tokens are millions and
millions of dollars people are out a
[__] ton of money because of it who's
still buying nfts Bro Dog nfts were such
a weird craze right the nft thing was
supposed to be something that was really
really good
yeah nfts were supposed to be originally
the idea that artists should be making
money off of their art because in the
digital world people could just steal
your [__] so it was supposed to be okay
look if I'm an artist right I create
this digital art well anybody can just
go right click save and post it and that
was it but if you give it a an actual
digital tag it shows the authenticity of
this so I could beam it anywhere we
could put it into a museum beam it and
it has like the authenticity tag
whatever the coding behind it and it
shows that this is an original art piece
like you do you could do with physical
art so if you want to buy this art it
was a way for an artist to be like okay
it sold for when I first saw this over a
hundred dollars right but now it's worth
a lot more it's worth 10 million well I
have coding in it that you could for
every time you sell it I get 10 of that
sale yeah so it was a way for artists to
make money off that was the cool part
that was a cool part of the tech but I
feel like a bunch of [__] took
advantage of it saw cash grab put out
their own version of it and then they
would [__] rug pull and that kept
happening so much where everybody was
like whoa [__] this thing yeah like
crypto zoo is stupid so you had these
eggs right and they're like oh this is
like some really digital artist [__] it
would be like oh it's a duck and a
[__] elephant put together and they
just spliced it together this is your
[__] animal it was a scam yeah you
know and somehow he still has a career
people don't [__] care he opens up a
drink called Prime right nobody gives a
[__] that he stole Millions from his
fans nobody [__] cares yeah that's
why when people complain about [__]
online all of you are a fake as [__]
none of you care about [__] so I'll say
and do whatever because guess what even
if I did [__] up which I won't you won't
care anymore but that's the truth it's
like no one really cares nobody will
like to seem like they care but they
don't actually yeah this is something
that's the that's the the name of the
game this podcast is brought to you by
raycon my friends what is raycon if you
don't know well now you know raycon is
premium audio at the perfect price point
so you could listen to what you want
when you want without breaking the Bank
my friends and let's face it with coffee
starting at five dollars in our bank
account somehow always depleting we are
officially entering a dupe session most
products do the same thing but are
priced differently solely based on the
brand name so a good duplicate or dupe
is crucify for getting the highest
quality at the best price one dupe you
shouldn't sleep on is raycon wireless
earbuds and the great thing about my
raycons is that they're priced perfectly
so and I tend to lose my earbuds a lot
that if I lost them anyways I can get
amazing earbuds at the proper price
price and replace them without losing an
arm and a lay you know what I'm saying
three customizable sound profiles here
but tap fungus has noise isolation and a
whole bunch more go to buy recon.com
brain today to get 15 off your raycon
order that's by raycon.com branding
score 15 off that's by raycon.com
speaking of that we should talk about
the Chris Rock special right yeah that's
that's the one that I really that's
great first of all tambourine I thought
was okay yeah me too I didn't really
like tambourine I thought it was okay it
was okay the one joke that I I do
remember from that though is where he
talks about how he cheated on his wife
yeah I think I cheated on my wife he's
like women you're like I know you're
like Chris Rock how could you that
you're a piece of [__] he's like I
cheated on like with three women he's
like you're a piece of [__] like how
could you do that yada yada like you're
an [__] and guys are like only three
women like you must have really loved
your wife dude
how about the UPS I got more [__]
than that
that's a good [__] joke but that's it
that's all I remember yeah so if you
guys don't know obviously you do Will
Smith slapped the living [__] [__]
out of Chris Rock right because uh he
spoke about Jada Pinkett Smith he made a
really soft joke too it was a GI Jane
joke right yeah it was like something
about yeah GI Jane sequel c yeah her
hair being uh [__] having a buzz cut
whatever yeah yeah yeah and honestly
that joke was soft as [__] and the funny
thing is if you look at that video clip
Will Smith was laughing at first and
then he saw his wife's face and then he
went from that to keep my name's wife
out your [__] mouth walks up to Chris
Rock and slaps the living [__] out of
him right yeah and then Chris Rock was
like yo what the [__] was that like I
can't believe that [__] just happened
and he moved on kept the professional
moved on so during this time Chris Rock
was touring he decided to make a special
and the reason why I like this special
because it was so different from his
last because now he has some [__] to
talk about exactly yeah it's on fire he
had some fear crazy how that [__] works
right and what I noticed too is he went
kind of back not completely to his old
Cadence but tambourine was like he was
kind of like he wasn't the Chris Rocco
you remember he used to pace and like he
had his very like maybe he had like that
style it was almost like a character
tamborine he went way away from that he
didn't do that at all this one he didn't
go completely back to it but he had some
of that he had that like the pace I was
like oh that's like the old Chris Rock
Cadence again like that like always
walking around he's doing the Muse the
music is there again yeah that yeah
where he repeats the premise over and
over and over like he beats the premise
in your [__] head and then like keeps
hitting you with the punches I think oh
that's like old Chris Rock dude that bit
even the bit about Will Smith that's not
even his funniest moment that was just
towards the end so that's literally what
he ends it with but the rest of his
stuff was him just saying like you know
what this is comedy I don't give a [__]
and that's what I was waiting for yeah
and that's what Dave Chappelle has yeah
and I think with Chris Rock I think life
has been so [__] good for him he
didn't have much to talk about and this
[__] he said everything that everybody
thinks but nobody says which is what
stand-up comedy is supposed to be that's
what it's supposed to be you know what I
heard a good critique I don't know I was
listening to a podcast it was I forgot
it was a comic talking about Chris Rock
and they were saying that before it
seemed like Chris Rock was trying to
like get like he was like wanted to be
in the Hollywood bubble you know what I
mean like he was really trying to be in
there so he was kind of like playing the
role
after Will Smith slapped the [__] out of
him and he was like what the f and no
one cared and they applauded Will Smith
won the award yeah he was kind of like
oh I'm on outside side like I'm an
outsider and it made him like open his
eyes to be like [__] these people and
then it was back to like I'm just a
comic now like [__] these [__]
I really appreciate that because if if
to be honest with you the comics that
are doing movies to me are some of the
worst Comics because they're too scared
now they have somebody in the news they
have somebody in their pockets yeah the
comics that just do comedy they don't
give a [__] yeah that's why Shane Gillis
is so [__] funny he doesn't care yeah
right he's he's been canceled yeah it's
like it's it's been done you know so
he's like [__] it Louie same thing Louie
got Stronger Yeah Louie's way funnier
now dude like a way funnier
and comedy is supposed to be comedy
right and like by the way I'm not saying
things can't be offensive like I've been
offended by Comics all the time but I'm
not sitting there saying cancel them I
just said like I didn't [__] like
that joke yeah guess what I move on with
my life exactly which is the way it
should [__] be yeah I didn't like it
I won't watch it I don't have to support
it I don't have to like tell everyone
else what they can't watch exactly but
somebody was laughing at that [__] right
yeah so like even with like okay
so with this special right the thing
that I loved about it the most is like
like you said he just doesn't care he
went back to his roots of not giving a
[__] there were some jokes in there like
I missed because he was throwing so many
jokes out so the second time I watched
it was in 10 times funny because there
was new jokes that I didn't hear before
because I was already laughing from the
previous one which that's when you know
a special is really good yeah yeah he
was making Draymond Green jokes yeah he
threw like five of them yeah it was
great he didn't care he was making some
good ass jokes he was making fun of his
kids yeah he had this bit about like the
private school thing about his kid was
so such a good bit dude so relatable all
this [__] was very down to earth and
relatable even my favorite bit even as a
rich person sure yeah right yeah yeah he
even throws like little subtle jokes
about like how people identify with [__]
right he goes like I'm rich but I
[__] identify as poor and these are
my habits and that was so relatable to
me right because even if you know I'm
doing financially well I'm the poor even
like my wife she's just like why are you
always on Facebook Marketplace and offer
up yeah I was like because it's a deal
it's a deal are you [__] like the
paper is full price yeah yeah this
camera right here full price plus tax
2798.42 cents
I got this 2100 that's amazing I'd love
to hear a good deal yeah yeah
it makes me happy this [__] made me
horny yeah yeah yeah what I do I saved
600 plus dollars yeah [__] my
dick got hard
because my dick
I was so that's what makes me hard
and so because I saw my other camera I'm
like grifting and thrifting [__] yeah
and I didn't pay [__] for this because I
stole all my old stuff and I got this
one [__] yeah that's what I love I don't
give a [__] he likes to give people
hand-me-downs too because he's like I'm
not gonna use it do you need it that's
good take it that's dope and you I can
see you get when you gave me an office
chair you were [__] a little chubbed
up yeah chubbed up because you were like
this is a good deal for you yeah hey man
you can get this deal or what
take the deal man take change it I need
you to take it if I can get something
[__] used and cheaper dog it gets my
rocks off
dude I [__] love that though I love
that Chris Rock came
the first 30 I saw I ins instantly like
within the first five minutes I was like
oh yeah he's back this [__]
what's it called one of the Jackson
family members I think it was like a
nephew or something
um clap back that Chris Rock where he
goes this man has been harassing my
family for years using it in comedy bits
and I'm like okay get out of here bro
you is it only Chris Rock or is it the
whole world the world so he's like and
he he got what he deserved I don't feel
sorry for him at all I don't think Chris
Rock gives a [__] about you yeah and
also hey you're allowed to feel like
that but also who gives a [__] about you
and what you think yeah you know like
you can feel that listen I'm not trying
to be unempathetic I understand but
listen I would get it if nobody did that
but it was only Chris Rock yeah
everybody makes Michael Jackson jokes
he's a punchline dude yeah every comic
has made a Michael Dave Chappelle did a
Michael Jackson bit everybody everybody
has let's be real your uncle Michael
Jackson is a [__] Legend [__]
was weird as [__] yeah it's yeah good
shot he was diddling those kids good
shot and also 75 Super Famous I even
give it 80. if he was a weirdo and he
just lived in Ohio
no one would talk about him yeah but he
was also the most famous musician of all
time who had the best-selling album ever
like of course [__] are gonna
talk about it the guy he's the dude how
dare you a [__] talk about my uncle
who was the most famous person on earth
right everybody's talking about him and
he was crazy weird and his best friend
was Macaulay Culkin oh yeah exactly so
what the [__] do you expect the guy
looked like a corpse yeah the voice of
an Angel yeah what did you expect
amazing dance moves I got kids
I'm proven we chances are he did but
some there's some [__] to talk about
yeah and to make fun about it but that's
unanswered questions there's some things
to discover and dig into
maybe he did or maybe he did it but if
you had to put your money on it gun to
your head which way are you going I
think he did for sure look any person
where you look at them and you go hey 50
50 chance he's a rapist he's kind of
weird yeah yeah nobody has ever said
that about anybody in this room here
that's where the where there's smoke
there's fire exactly yeah like it makes
sense if you're at the 50 Mark you're
pretty much yeah like rape dude rape and
then you put a that you put the child
part before it you're already like
you're in a special Club exactly over
the span of decades yeah like this stuck
with you
yeah you can't you could have shaked
this one some jokes are gonna be cracked
yeah I'll tell you this still like when
you're [__] infamy is as popular as
the good [__] you've done there's a
problem yeah that's why that is the
greatest musician that has ever lived
yeah that touched kids yeah yeah this is
a [__] problem damn that's true or
they give you a pass of how good your
music is but then they always have to
bring up like yeah like I didn't even
think about that but you're right the
infamy was as like a percentage-wise as
high as his music Talent exactly exactly
is really good at music in the Dark
Realm he was just as powerful
that's crazy versus the darkness
I think it's talented if I put my money
on it
he's good at everything this guy God
damn that's tough now his nephew's gonna
put the article about us but look I
would say this the only reason why at
the end I decided that he wasn't
touching these kids and in a sexual way
was because of one [__] clip Michael
Jackson was it a limo
Oprah then the girl came up with the
titties yeah he goes goddamn look at
them things
yeah like moved over to the side like oh
[__]
where I'm like this motherfucker's weird
he's weird so that's what I saw that he
didn't did all those kids okay no way a
kid did was gonna look at two [__]
leche duffels yeah
admit interview yeah Oprah chilling they
got a camera crew in there and he like
couldn't even be bothered yeah exactly
and he goes look at them exactly look at
the Pelosi's he was calling them yeah
probably because she was seven at the
time
laughs
[Laughter]
don't look into it don't look into it
but we get it you know they're just yeah
but that was a weird and then but then
you if you rewind a couple years he's
like going to the mall with kids yeah
you know it's just no matter what when
you look at that it's always going to
seem a little odd there's no way you're
gonna do that and then defend yourself
and you're gonna look good yeah like if
you saw me at a mall and I was just
hanging out with little kids I was like
listen for me I identify with these kids
yeah like they're they're the best if
you're an adult you can't be around
random kids yeah that aren't your own
kids that aren't your own if you're not
a school teacher or like your job
doesn't revolve around and you're the
most famous person in the world at that
time yeah and you have a red flag a
whole place called Neverland where I
hang out with kids only that's kid
material only and then I think a lot of
people that like go the opposite side of
like no he's innocent they always go
like well he didn't do anything with
Macaulay like that's their evidence and
it's like that's one kid that's one yeah
also you know this is also the most
famous guy so high profile yeah yeah you
gotta be smart and you got to be smart
about yourself he wanted to I'm sure
probably but he couldn't steal the deal
the other thing that people use in
defense is that okay he had his
childhood taken away from very abusive
father the guy was a [__] Maniac bro
he looks crazy dude he looks he doesn't
even look like he looks like the dad
looks like the devil dude do his
eyebrows he looks like he looks like the
guy he looks like Uncle Ruckus from
Boondocks yeah
based off him right for sure evil
[__] eyebrows he looks like demonic
and so it looks like a pneumonia
the biggest defense is that what he got
his childhood taken away from him so
he's trying to relive his childhood
because of all the mental trauma he has
I give him that but there's no way at
first of all [__] the parents yeah first
of all because like they're weird too
like send your kids off to hang out with
this 40 year old man and then have a
summer party
yeah stranger danger yeah they're not
they're not innocent either yeah at all
at all but even like the relive your
childhood thing it's like okay I get it
but like that you don't you don't do
that though yeah
you know if you want to relive your
childhood like go to Disneyland by
yourself and like buy get the ears and
[__] yeah you're just gonna get old
quick adult friends and do that if
you're not into molesting kids that's
just gonna get old real quick oh you'll
tell you this Michael Jackson has a
funny there was this interview that I
saw it was him in Oprah and Oprah's
trying to do an interview with him and
talk to him but this will so into his
dancing that she's asking him questions
he goes so Michael
laughs
hey Michael so what have you done with
your next two what
happened
bro those clips are [__] legendary
you don't give a [__] dude I feel like
you just [__] messing with her the
whole time or maybe that's what he's
really like yeah still proven guilty so
Michael Jackson because you're not
proven guilty you are innocent in my
eyes for now and look I don't want to
believe in that stuff because I also
don't want to believe that these kids
were touched inappropriately yeah so for
me I'm gonna believe that what if
they're saying it though
if they're saying it then that's a
problem what if they're adults now and
they're saying well then I believe the
kids then 100 yeah because that's just
some weird [__] yeah yeah I never wanted
the slumber party with a bunch of kids
but I'll tell you this story so dude
that's weird that's weird well my my
parents used to do these like Bible
study groups right as um where they
would at night time they would have a
bunch of people from the church and they
would pray together worship eat food
grub and chop it up but they would have
little kids and I'm like 15 at the time
and I'm sleeping in my room and then
these kids still they want to play and
they're in my room at night my mom's
just playing with them I was like Mom no
it's [__] night time and there's
little kids in my room get the [__] out
of my room that's weird you know but
their parents are just like oh you know
yeah yeah they just want to play with
their older brother sibling because I
just was telling them like this doesn't
look right like it doesn't matter if you
trust me right you shouldn't send your
kids in the room with a 15 year old kid
weird you know I understand why parents
are so sometimes aloof because they know
me right but I was just telling them
they like you so much yeah and I
couldn't explain to me I couldn't speak
Korean parent right now yeah they just
don't want to pair like you guys you
take care of them like no I'm 15. yeah
and I shouldn't be hanging out with
five-year-olds in my room yeah exactly
you know what I mean so I just like no
tell them to leave my room and I'm Gonna
Be in My Room by myself and I would just
really weirded out by that [__] but my
parents didn't but the parents didn't
get it they're like What's the problem
just babysit them I'm like no no this is
weird yeah you know what I mean you guys
don't understand how good this is and
this is me as a 15 year old kid I
thought it was odd yeah dude if I'm at
the park like I'll be at the park with
Maya I'm with my daughter and like if
she runs off and then another kid
because sometimes kids will come up to
you and like want to play with you
they're random kids
I'm very like where the [__] is this
kid's parents and like I I like I like
maybe
I'm like yo like my hands are here dude
yeah cause I'm just a dude right like
they don't know like my I'm they assume
my kid's around but I'm a dude and I I'm
very like I get uncomfortable I'm like
dude where's your parents look my hands
are here I'm not trying to [__] a kid my
daughter's right over there it's we it's
like it's not chill right over there
yeah
[Laughter]
dude like a kid who like came up to me
and like wanted so I was holding my on
the monkey bars and like I I she can't
do it by herself she's [__] weak so
I'll like hold up
I hold her and I help her and this other
kid random kid came up to me and was
like hey can you help me and I was like
like I don't want to [__] where's
your dad I'm not gonna pick this random
I want to help the kid because it's like
I wanna like I want him to have a good
time but like I'm not trying to pick
this rainbow it's not gonna touch it
isn't it so sad that we live in this
type of world now yeah or you can't even
help a kid without somebody looking at
you like you're a creep and I get it too
because I don't trust nobody even with
my friends kids if some random person
comes up I'm like who the [__] are you
yeah you're right you know if someone
dudes holding Maya I would go over there
and be like who the [__] are you I'm
gonna beat your [__] echo my [__]
daughter you creepy weirdo yeah the [__]
yeah I was especially in this climate in
this day today unless it's somebody that
I under like I know like it was one of
you guys like oh cool all right yeah
but like dude some [__] Rando just
holding your kid these people just [__]
dog like dude I think they recently
released um audio recordings of like
Jared Fogle the subway I don't know why
I left but uh the subway guy you know
because he went to jail if you guys
don't know for people who are a little
younger who might be listening to this
Jared Fogle was the spokesperson for
Subway he was about like 300 plus pounds
huge and his whole campaign was that he
lost weight during Subway and his
campaign brought a lot of money to
Subway I know because I ate a lot of
Subway because of it everybody did it
was the hottest thing yeah and Stephanie
put his even [__] meatball parms for
lunch yeah and I think even about losing
weight even before California made the
law that you have to put the calories
onto your food I think Subway was doing
that before Oh [__] right I think so
because they I remember they were doing
macro counting so this this sub this
seven witch sandwich with no mayo is
only 320 calories so you could calorie
count so it blew up Subway they were
making a [__] ton of money turns out FBI
did a raid they found that he had a bump
[__] ton of kids I'm talking okay look
you got like I don't know six or seven
files of kitty porn already disgusting
this guy had terabytes Jesus hard drives
upon hard drives of this [__] he was a
sick [__] everybody so they found
recordings or they released recordings
of him talking to somebody about hey
dude you can go to Thailand and [__]
these kids oh
dude Subway must be so [__] pissed
out of all the guys that they could have
gotten that was like really heavy and
lost weight they picked the guy who was
watching terabytes of child porn in
disgusting that's the only guy they
could have found bro like they're lucky
enough only six things you said I want a
smaller I want a petite and small I'll
take the six-year-old I mean
world that we live in is [__]
disgusting man yeah it's weird I really
do think
I'm not saying he was probably like this
even before the [__] Fame but like
that thing gave him access to [__] that
he never had access to before no the
money everything yeah like just like
Holly was really [__] weird like
nobody is ever honest in this world you
know I think the thing that I got sick
of the most and the reason why like I
enjoy doing podcasts and doing what we
do here is because I could say what I
like or dislike and I have no
inclination to not say it because people
will do this where they'll objectively
see a project that another fellow actor
is in right and they'll see them they go
dude you're so amazing in that project
and they know that it sucks instead of
just being looking at hey bro that
[__] movie we're [__] pretty bad
huh right why can't you just say that
yeah yeah why can't you just say it I
feel you do that here a lot a lot yeah I
do that to their face too and they get
shocked
what do you mean you know why because it
sucks let me tell you let me tell you
exactly what it's at the bottom I guess
about how terrible it is yeah yeah and
it's okay too it's okay normal people
would do that but it just I I think
especially like too in like the acting
world I mean I'm speaking I'm speaking
generally but like there's like that
like kind of I don't know that just
there's like that fakeness about it yes
and that's the difference with like
comedians it's like ball bustings in the
in the culture so they will tell you
like you come from like a comedy
background so you're not afraid to be
like yo that [__] was [__] whack and
people you know like not everyone is
thin skinned around in your world so
they're like yeah you know the way you
should take that is be like okay that's
your opinion and like hopefully take the
right criticism from it apply it to the
next movie but yeah Hollywood type [__]
everyone's I just hate it when people
come up to each other and they do do
that and they talk [__] about it behind
their back just say to their face right
which is the way it should be done yeah
and it's completely fine because guess
what you're not going to be great at
everything that you do look at look at
uh bus's name [__] a Brendan's shop
like all of his peers made fun of his
special and they're still friends yeah
right because they didn't like it really
though I don't know what's going on the
the the Mufasa guy just had a falling
out
the member of The Arrow Hawaii was like
the washed up Mufasa looking character
it was like the the dude so they just
had a falling out I was just watching a
bunch of [__] I was like what the [__]
they had a falling out oh that random
Buffy he looks like he has Botox on his
lips and [__] he was like the guy he was
their manager or something but he just
got fired and now he's like on this
whole tour of talking [__] about them
damn bro I was like what the [__] is
going on
uh Mark some [__] yeah he does it look a
lion I'm not trying to like search it up
but like I just saw this like last week
where he's like on this tour about like
talking [__] about I mean that kind of
makes it like what the [__] is going on
listen that's
I'm so tired of just like [__] on
Brenda's job you know I mean like let
that let the boy live man let the boy
live you're going through it all yeah I
feel like he's going through it for sure
you know what I do say I appreciate
about him like at least he's he's a
[__] on the road working all the time
dude yeah yeah like he's trying to get
better 24 [__] seven I don't know I
can't speak about him personally because
we're not friends like that you know
what I'm saying so I have nothing to say
about his personal life only the stuff
that I see online and I'll talk about it
because it's a topic but just like for
you to lose your job and then your first
thing is like okay now for it's time for
me to get my fame and go on this tour
might not be the best look for him right
because that thing is going to last for
how long yeah no I'm just saying that it
just there's always conflict around that
team like that's that's the thing that I
see I just see like anytime there's like
constant conflict around a certain
person or team it's like what the [__]
is going on CT got hit in the head too
much or something what's like what's
happening you know I don't know what it
is dude but he he's constantly dripped
in drama too people like look at the
tiger belly stuff too they constantly
talk [__] about kalila 24 [__] seven
Bobby needs to leave
and the funny thing is is you know this
is people from the outside perspective
who look at tigerbelly as if tigerbelly
like Bobby runs the show 24 7. like
they're a full-on-ass team yeah
everybody plays their part the one thing
that Bobby is the entertainment right
everybody runs the back end so which is
they've been open about that [__] but
they go if it wasn't for Bobby this show
wouldn't happen no if it wasn't for them
the show wouldn't happen yeah it would
literally would not happen because I
know this from an artist perspective
right when you're just focused on being
an artist you actually don't know how to
do [__] you don't you absolutely have
like like Bobby's not like me he doesn't
know equipment camera lighting all this
other stuff he doesn't know how to grow
tomatoes bro yeah let me tell you let me
guess this [__] can I say
something real quick
oh you continue I'll explain it we're at
the gym we're all lifting weights
together there's like four or five guys
okay Marlin of all people Marlin's one
of our our boys who train he's a great
trainer he's a sweet sweet boy sweet guy
but you know how he is he's a free
spirit and [__] free spirit I love the
guy like he's great
him and David start talking about
irrigating Tomatoes dude
bro look at this [__] what the [__] and
it's like dude in my head I'm laughing
because I'm like David goes into this
like 15 minute tirade about like all the
things you need to do to create tomatoes
and he's using
like uh he's using voice baby that's
what you need he's using vocabulary that
I've never even like you know you need
to get the nematodes and I was like what
the f that's a real [__] thing he's
going off on this tangent and in my head
I'm like this is the most David thing in
the world because the most David thing
in the world is him knowing all the
inner workings of any specific topic way
too long talking way too much about it
and he just deep Dives so hard we're
like oh of course David knows how to
make
two varieties of tomatoes you just get
obsessed with [__] and just dive in so I
got diagnosed with ADHD
it's pretty severe and even before I got
diagnosed I already knew I had it yeah
yeah you know so one of the things like
you know we get very into things and we
move on from things really fast so we
have trouble like paying attention to
conversations
um that's why usually all my friends
that have are really weird they're
[__] oddballs you [__] weird [__]
I'm not weird and so pretty normal dog I
think this right here my friends are
black princes black princes yes they
they drew me a little slower no this is
what they're actually called they're
called black princesses here we have
fake it easy
[Music]
my friends is a beefsteak tomato which
is the heirloom that you typically see a
lot that's probably the only ones that
you could really get in grocery stores
pretty consistently uh when it grows
these right here is David's hair right
here these right here are what Sprouts
first so this is this right here are
pretty much the useless of these
right that's the good stuff this is the
good [__] right so this is when they
photosynthesize and after this you could
pluck these off the great thing about
tomatoes my friends is that they have
these little little Furs they're one of
the few plants that actually can grow
roots from the stem so you can bury it
deep right fantastic so with this
battery why is that advantageous because
it prevents you can grow a really strong
root system so when you grow tomatoes
right my friends yeah you don't want to
grow in small bags because you want a
strong roots because they're feeders and
they'll feed out a lot okay so what I'm
going to do is plant this in a cup and
from the cup they're going to grow
strong roots it's about put into a
bigger bag and a bigger bag so it has a
stronger chance of surviving uh heirloom
tomatoes are Delicious By the way see
it's fascinating so so you this is
[__] amazing it's amazing so you
bought these little pods is that so
these right here are um they're
basically Peach starter pods right so
they come out in these little pucks are
about this small you fill it with water
they expand
um they're great because they retain a
lot of moisture which seedlings need and
for it to stay consistently moist so it
could Sprout so they on average if you
if it stays about like 60 degrees so
you'll get like a heat mat or if you
have a stunning window that's good too
but the warmer that it is if it stays
from 60 that I believe like 70 or 80
degrees uh it'll Sprout within seven
days oh wow see what I'm talking about
dude yeah and it's just so thorough it's
crazy so how long before it actually
starts showing Tomatoes by three months
which is actually pretty fast uh for
most things that bear fruit right so if
you look at fruit trees they take years
yeah that's why when people like oh I'm
growing this avocado tree from this pit
hey you're gonna get avocados in 20
years idiot
speed it up jerk off go get a [__]
tree that's already done yeah yeah
so Jesus Christ I gotta wait three rolls
that property brother but whatever
whenever I see people do that I got this
avocado tree I'm gonna get avocado soon
20 years from now yeah dumbass you know
so this is a girl really [__] slow
it's a [__] tree idiot
but Tomatoes too if you guys don't know
if you guys had tomatoes your whole life
right and you go these things are always
flavorless that's because like tomato
commercially grown tomatoes usually
taste pretty bad they just taste like
water the ones that you grow at home
[__] delicious they actually have
flavor so ever since I had it then I've
never been able to go back you love
tomatoes and now I love tomatoes those
are bomb my favorite varieties are a
sunglasses so defensive
I have 72 plants including all this holy
[__] if you want plants I'm only gonna
grow eight of them so I'm giving them
away oh yeah I'll take some for sure so
let's go baby are they easy to maintain
like is it hard to take care of them or
uh I'll teach you how to do it okay okay
but one sounds like it's pretty hard
dude I'm down though you have the
sunlight for it it's just dope so people
who listens probably hate me right now
I like Martha Stewart should I love it
so you have like two different types of
tomatoes right you have determinants and
indeterminants uh determinants are they
have a set amount of fruit that they're
going to produce indeterminants stop
producing fruits when the season ends so
if you start from Spring and let's say
you do it indoors you could technically
grow tomatoes year-round non-stop like a
perennial wow so uh people will do
Hydroponics indoors so for example my
buddy Robin started his Tomatoes last
year spring and he's they're dying now
but they still have some tomato fruits
on it even after a whole year wow so as
long as the weather stays warm and then
the season technically doesn't end it'll
continue to grow fruit so if I start
this tomato plant here in this corner of
this wall that plant will keep growing
like a Vine whoa and it'll produce more
and more fruit so people actually grow
tomato trees or they'll trellis it all
the way up to about eight feet tall wow
and it'll produce fruit consistently
holy [__] so indeterminate tomatoes
brother pretty [__] amazing Sun Golds
which are really popular they're like
cherry tomatoes but they're yellow they
actually taste like tropical fruits
really they're [__] delicious wow
like one of these you're gonna plant
some you're gonna make some of those on
that one I'm actually planting three I
want some of those yeah well guess what
I can give you one and you could try
taking care of it well I I just don't
have we can't even keep a [__] an
aloe plant in our [__] house plant
murderer I see
um we have we have terrible sunlight
so these right here are actually ready
to plant and put in the cups I just need
to buy some Solo cups for it whenever
you're ready I'll give you some [__]
tomatoes in three months you'll have the
best tomatoes I want some Tomatoes bro
how big do the Cups have to be they're
just Solo cups like that I'm already
give it to you set up so I'm gonna give
it to people when the roots are set so
they have a better chance of surviving
yeah and then all you need to do is get
a grow bag
um get some loose fitting soil so
basically you can get it the bag will
say
um potting soil right before you plant
it um the problem is that when you put
it in bags they lack calcium which
eventually develops them getting
something called root at like n rot
which is something you don't want so I
have gypsum so I'll just put like a bit
of gypsum in there some gypsum I don't I
don't even know it's calcium he said it
like we're supposed to know calcium okay
okay so yeah disrespectful it's a group
of people so if you're gonna make chips
these grow bags by the way are like you
can get like 10 of them for like [__]
20 bucks yeah so um you're just probably
only gonna need two okay all right
because you're not gonna grow this many
tomatoes sure I have a bunch of like
Chef friends I'm gonna give it out too
that's what I'm going seven that's six
and then um plant it put it with calcium
put a little bit of phosphate in there I
had that as well for you
um because you just need a handful of
and you only do it once and then after
that just fertilize every two weeks and
keep it consistently watered one of the
biggest problems that people have with
tomatoes is that they over water or the
underwater the best way to do it is to
do it through an oil system which is
just a oil system what the [__] is that
so you get an oil which is I think it's
African I apologize but they the
terracotta pot actually releases
moisture so the plant will grow roots
around the terracotta pot and it'll only
take as much water as it needs so it
will never over water I heard terracotta
really is the way to go yeah so you put
the terracotta pot into the bag okay and
then you put the water in it and all you
have to do is put water into the pot
instead of the soil so it never gets
over watered or underwater because the
plant will take as much as it needs wow
so you don't even have to worry about it
and you just water every three or four
days and you're pretty much good to go
and then just fertilize every two weeks
can you believe that we started talking
about Michael Jackson diddling kids and
now he's talking about the irrigation
systems do you need to [__]
terracotta Tomatoes baby and oil
irrigation system could you believe
that's how this conversation went I love
it dude honestly I [__] love plants I
I've I've started I have a few at the
house and I've just trial I just got
into it I just like I bought a bunch of
plants and I was like I'm gonna figure
this [__] out one of my I had a money
tree root rot like a [__] I
replanted it I don't know what the [__]
I did wrong you over watered it I think
I over watered it fruit rot like a
pasture you're talking it smells came
out it just like did like just mushed on
the bottom like all right these fools
died I gotta try again but I have the
little what do they call the pot house
potholes pot house the the usual typical
hanging plants oh yeah those are pretty
easy to take care of but those guys are
going strong I have a rubber tooth right
here yeah yeah I have a rubber plant
that's going pretty strong that I
brought back from the dead but I've had
a couple like a fern that [__] died
that just I don't know what the [__]
happened in the money tree died so what
the the biggest mistake that people make
with those trees right money trees are
trees so they store a lot of water into
their trunks they actually don't need to
be watered too much so there's a few
plants that don't need to be watered a
lot so rubber trees they drink a lot of
water so they're actually really easy to
care for Money Trees you could plant
them in like minimal sunlight just have
it in a shady spot but it gets like
indirect sunlight and it'll do perfectly
fine so once you check the soil you'll
see the leaves they'll feel like a
little rubbery where just give it some
water then so you can probably water
them every like two or three weeks and
you're pretty much good to go so yeah it
was it was cool for a long time and then
I repotted it because I heard someone
say that you should repost it did that
it started I don't know and then it just
[__] fell apart from that point on maybe
I [__] The Roots up or something yeah
once you get root rot what you have to
do is you have to clean the roots very
thoroughly yeah so you have to wash it
that's what happened with this yeah I
didn't take care of it had root rot so I
just planted in the water and it came
back to life yeah but hydrogen peroxide
spray it out and then um wash it out
with water and then plant it back in and
it's pretty much good to go so uh rubber
trees are very easy ZZ plants are a
really good starter plant you only need
to water that ZZ plant maybe every month
and a half to two months damn so the ZZ
plant it'll grow out very strong grows
in like minimal minimal sunlight and on
top of that they have these like sacks
underneath the extra the root system
that actually collect and store water so
you don't have to water it that much so
if you're going away for a long time you
can [__] leave that [__] for a month
oh man that's awesome perfect
there were just a couple plant daddies
over here bro it's crazy to watch you
guys just go off and I'm just like what
bro plants you should get into plants I
want to but it just we we we kill our
plants at the Dunn household all our
plants are dying so if you guys ever
wanted indoor plants like the easiest
plants to get in my personal opinion any
type of rubber plant right Money Trees
snake plants yeah we got a monstera
monsters are pretty easy too they don't
need to be watered much the great thing
about monsters are they actually like to
be potted into smaller smaller pots so
if you put them into a lot of soil they
actually don't like it I just never knew
you were like this enough it's wild how
much you know about plants that's what
I'm saying is that a trip that's what
I'm talking about yeah it's some [__]
like this where we yeah he just goes off
and I'm like dude you're speaking
another language I it's got the Torres
Tomatoes I can't [__] tell Dude I
literally don't sleep yeah I I read up
[__] so I've learned to shut my phone
off at night because I'll go and learn
like a [__] about useless [__]
no it doesn't help my career at all
that's awesome dude so I get super into
things right like Monsters too I also
found out about the smaller potting
thing actually bear fruit what kind of
fruit it's a monster fruit it looks like
a pine cone and it's actually very very
sweet so if you it'll shed its outer
layer but if you eat it before it
naturally sheds it off you should be
able to tap it and it sheds off it'll
actually create these little like
microscopic spikes that'll [__] up your
throat oh but it tastes like a mix
between like guava and banana okay yeah
what the [__] they're very hard to grow
here because we don't have the climate
it needs to be very very humid uh so if
you get like monstera fruit then that
means you need to have a humid
humidifier a humidifier next to it and
the fruit will grow maybe but we're not
in the climate for it so it's pretty
[__] cool man damn bro stir or fruit
did you think we're gonna talk about
that I had no idea what a monstera was
before 10 minutes ago yeah dude monsters
are [__] great man if you guys ever
get into plants it's nice to take care
of something too it is sick yeah yeah
plants are dope dude it's satisfying to
see like your work pay off that's why I
stopped caring about it started with
house plants and then I started
gardening yeah at least I could eat my
[__] yeah no that gardening is
definitely where it's at no I bet once
you grow like your first crop of
tomatoes that's probably the most
satisfying thing ever I've always
fantasized about having my own home
Garden where I wrote my own [__] tomato
people as well if you do plant tomatoes
make sure that you grow companion plants
with it as well to get rid of insects so
marigolds and also basil really good
with it
wow who would have [__] thought
that's amazing dude 100 dude you could
just grow your [__] think about it like
this right if you get a pack of cilantro
seeds right it's like [__] three four
dollars you just throw that down they
grow like [__] weeds and you have
cilantro for [__] five six months and
you just spend three dollars on it
because it is annoying to have to go to
the store and buy something 100 do that
I planted I planted literally 12 of them
into the soil and they're sprouted
already like these cute little little
sprouts and they're gonna grow great
thing about cilantro weird thing about
cilantro that people don't know is
actually a cold weather [__] herb
even though we eat it a lot during the
summer time so what happens when it gets
too hot they actually Sprout flowers and
they start to germinate oh okay and
which isn't great but the the flowers of
the cilantro taste really [__] good
really it's like an intense cilantro
flavor oh wow really so you could so
you'll see a lot of chefy types use it
as garnish so I don't mind if it's
Sprouts I'll just eat this I'll eat the
flowers as well and they're [__]
delicious dude and some really dope
garnish parsley as well basil super easy
where my question where because I heard
there's certain seeds like picking your
seeds is important right like you don't
there's certain seeds that are
apparently
like I I don't know if I'm explaining so
people will do like they'll get oh I
want like non-GMO seeds yeah I want like
Heirloom Seeds um that are organic and
honestly like when you first start who
the [__] cares it doesn't matter just
make sure that when you plant your seeds
plant two or three at the same time
because not all of them are going to
germinate right so that's what the
guarantee that you get from like really
reputable sources like they'll they'll
germinate like for me I got some
reputable sources I assume that some of
them weren't going to sprout every
single one then that's why I have 72
[__] tomato plants so like these ones
sprouted really late the black princess
look how small these are black princes
these ones sprouted really [__]
Prince
um Michael Jackson was a black princess
at one point these are my MJS these are
my MJ docs and I got my LGBT uh rainbows
these are the rainbow Tomatoes hell yeah
dude they shouldn't even be this big in
the street Sprout once they sprout I
should have already planted and
transferred okay plant the [__]
dude I just have to water them every day
now but um once these are pretty much
good to go so I'm gonna plant these
probably because that's awesome I love
that that's cool [__] yeah you're
inspiring to plant some [__] cilantro
because I always run out of cilantro
I'll tell you when I first saw these
things the seedlings Sprout but I was so
[__] happy yeah I bet yeah and then
no satisfying I'll show you the ones in
the garage man and there's some outside
too that I'm actually going to give the
Marlin and you now and I have like five
other people who want these so I'm gonna
give you like four or five because
you'll probably kill like three of them
anyways because you know it's your first
time you need a companion plan dude I
have basil at the house right now yeah
just [__] put some basil so in the
grow bag right just you could either put
a terracotta spike in there and I'll
show you all that [__] and then you just
put like a button it'll take the water
that needs that's what I suggest
um or what you can do is in that same
bag plant um basil into it okay and then
it'll help with pests okay because one
of the things that it'll get is like
mites and like um like this Dusty mold
type of [__] okay but basil helps with
that and also marigolds and marigolds
are just pretty it's an African flower
okay and it grows during the Spring
beautiful [__]
um oh that's [__] awesome we're going
off right you're ready spitting right
you're ready for the apocalypse
like I literally had the hardest time
sleeping like I legit
I don't I should not know this much
about tomatoes but at least you're
productive most people like if I'm not
sleeping I'm on YouTube or I'm jerking
off or something you know what I mean
like I'm not learning about [__]
Agriculture and learning how to create
the [__] new beings and eat tomatoes
and [__] you know what I mean
when the apocalypse comes you guys
already eat a lot of tomatoes damn I'm
ready ready dog very high on lycopene
which is great for cell regeneration
[Laughter]
we have Nick the ear here the man with
the smallest penis that you've ever seen
in your life these eggplants for a
reason sometimes it is crazy where
you're like dude I didn't know my penis
can get that small yeah that's crazy
dude and then we have Pat we call them
the elephantitis dick because he was
surprised how large and lumpy it is
that [__] weird
a little fungal infection on that [__]
all right here we go The Last of Us the
dick version uh you catching this brain
every Sundays at 12 p.m Nick at Nick the
ear patrick.t.rlly
come out he's doing stand-up once again
baby see him at his shows boom throw
some Tomatoes at him let's go let's get
it everybody love us long time